hey how's it going bros my name is
pierre Takei
I'm playing kitty cat jigsaw puzzles but
I'm not here to talk about the gameplay
even though it does get pretty sick
later on get a nuke at the end
I'm currently sick so I apologize for
the lack of face cam but that's okay I
wanted to make this video anyway since a
lot of you have been commenting saying
that my content has been getting better
lately I wanted to give you guys my
warmest way of saying don't get used to
it if you're new here you should know
that my content will always be garbage
and my jokes will always be
cringe-worthy thank you very much though
but yeah my channel had a bit of a
second wind over the summer if you look
at the graph here my views have been
going down for the longest time despite
many efforts and the only reason anyone
is probably still watching is because my
ego is now so massive that I call people
out on [ __ ] that I even do myself I'm
probably the biggest hypocrite on
YouTube but at the same time at least
I'm aware of all this you could say I
finally became self-aware and that's
when my content started to become less
garbage you can see it here on the graph
to be fair though I owe a massive thanks
to Michael and Brad for helping me out
with videos lately you've probably seen
them in some of my videos I had for the
longest time the approach to YouTube
that I had to do everything by myself
and I would say this a lot but I see now
how absolutely depressing that was for
four years is sitting alone by myself in
front of a computer every single day
it's just it's just [ __ ] sad I
honestly can't remember having any
interests or liking anything else but
YouTube at the time and I think if you'd
asked me I probably would have just said
YouTube but my biggest thanks I owe to
you bros for watching my videos over the
years I know make a lot of dumb jokes
and I know it might seem like I don't
care but
I really do and it means the world that
you bros are watching my videos so thank
you now I don't know if my views will
keep growing from this point although we
all know it's all about the watch time
now but I do know that I'm finally
enjoying making videos every single day
and I think that shows in my content I
feel like I'm back again we are now at
47 million subscribers which is probably
the dumbest number I could possibly
think of but I do appreciate every
single one of you and thank you for
watching this has been kitty cat jigsaw
gameplay I realized I finished this
video 7 minutes too early and most
youtubers would probably just ramble on
for this time period but I am just going
to keep the gameplay going for the
remainder as an attempt of an ironic
joke that I'm still very much profiting
off ah thank you so much for watching
and as always stay awesome bros
you